hey guys let's benefit to a gene from ta
checker here and in this video I wanted
to see how much money it can be made at
door now as you guys know apart maybe
you don't know a few weeks ago exactly
on May 25th was possibly the biggest
change to happen to old school and in a
very long time and it was was balancing
changed to these old laptop table and
one of the key factors in this here is
that they said that they dropped the
average loot from zola by 30% so
initially I wanted to go out and try
killings over a thousand times and
seeing what the overall loop was from
that but after killing it 500 times I
just couldn't do it anymore
because um this is going to be a
subjective opinion and some of you guys
may feel differently but after killing
at 500 times it just felt like it just
wasn't even worth it
in terms of making money and I'm going
to leave that up to you guys to decide
on whether or not this is the boss that
you want to kill for money but the
entire time that I tried killings over
there pretty much the whole time pretty
much the whole place was a ghost town
normally before this before this nerf
came around you would see the place
highly populated you see like at least
five people walking through like three
people sitting at the at the pier just
waiting the kills or just hanging out
but now there was like literally no one
and I after after all the five hundred
kills there was only like maybe one
other person or maybe two other people
who are also killing missoura with one
of those being someone who was a high
level like Mac's player with a Tebow but
with a twisted belt trying to camp it
for the pet
so obviously this change was significant
and despite them saying this was nerfed
by 30% I feel it feels like the nerf was
a lot bigger
30% and I have over here on the side
just a little strange out here and I'm a
screenshot I'm not showing the entire
loot yet so I have that they're ready to
kind of go over and kind of sell all the
loot see what it's worth and all that
kind of stuff and then I'm going to do
some calculations at the end of it to
see if this was really nerve by 30%
based upon the loot that I got and I
feel like 500 kills is sufficient enough
of a data set to determine you know kind
of roughly whether or not this was
worked by that much and whether or not
if you decide to kill this box for money
personally if you're a high level PBM er
I I couldn't see it's suggesting this
for anyone I mean you're literally
better off killing been DOS or going to
God wars raids basically anywhere else
except Sora this nerf basically killed
the boss entirely did this boss need a
nerf sure but I think this nerf was
really hard this was a massive nerves
and it basically just killed the boss
let's get into this to see what kind of
changes might have happened to this
alright guys so here we are we have our
loot from $500 kills and just see you
guys can see let me hype out PC Zorro
and I started keep in mind I started at
1,000 to make it an even number and then
we did an extra Bionicles
which we have here in our cab right now
now some things that aren't included in
the drops where these venom potions
ranging potions so everything up here on
the top besides these scales or not
goodies and drop obviously application
for the do not drop by Zola and then
everything below everything below this
line is a drop Ozora now one thing
that's pretty neat about oh it's buddy
I'm not sure if this is a pro pitcher or
not I've always been a pro member of OS
buddy so I don't know
works for everyone else but on the side
you can see it'll keep tabs of the boss
that you're killing and then the drop
that it had and show you basically the
average it'll keep tabs on the loot and
this is only a small picture or snapshot
of the amount of the amount of loot that
I got from Zara because this is only 45
of them I think the biggest data set
that I got out of this from OS buddy
well keep it open was around 200 kills
and with 200 kills the average loot that
was showing was about 78 K and that's
just going off of memory so that's not
like a solid you know state picture that
I can provide for you guys but from from
that 200 kills that I got from Zora and
showing a 78k Everidge loot that also
included the serpentine visage that I
got so that the size I have here was
included in that 7 date average 7 8 k
average loot so that's a pretty big
difference right off the bat from what
it used to be but why don't we go ahead
and try and price check all of this
[Music]
you
Oh
[Music]
ha
the
[Music]
Oh
total amount is 56.1 male out of 500
kills now that might seem like a lot to
some of you players out there but but
again like I said if you've been killing
Zorro before the nerve then this is a
pretty big difference and it it pretty
much tells when you look at the place
when you when you go to that place to go
tales all right it's basically a ghost
town and that boss is dead it took me
quite a while to get those five energy
gels so there's a lot more bosses that I
could kill or there's a lot of other
things that I could do to make the 56
mill which would have been a lot quicker
notably I could have been doing raids I
could have been doing ser Dolman kind of
been doing Bandos basically anything
other than zora again that's a that's a
subject that's a subjective opinion and
it's really achieve that's determine
whether or not this is something you
want to kill but that is my loot from
500 kills and then notably I've also got
the tanzanite mutagen one of the reasons
I did this see that this little kill
count thing was so that I could try and
camp a pet as well but again after
killing it you know 500 times I just
couldn't do it anymore
with the amount of money that I was
getting from it which is painfully slow
at least for me it may not be for any of
the other yep any of you other guys out
there it might seem like a lot of money
and I was very lucky enough to get a
tenth and I mutagen and before you get
upset at me for getting one of these for
such a low kill count because I know
that is really rare to get I know people
try and get like 10,000 kill counties
don't have a mutagen you're mine I share
your pain because I'm still trying to
get the runecrafting pet 99 runecrafting
18.2 almost eighteen point three mil XP
and I still don't have the pet so for
those of you guys who are out there
saying while you're so lucky I don't I
don't feel that lucky because I still
don't have the pet that I really want to
go for I basically have no pet
all but I was very lucky enough to get
the mutagen and I do realize that it was
it was very lucky to get that I just
know that we've actually sold all the
loot why don't we actually get into the
actual analytics of everything that
actually has happened with the nerves
and all that kind of jazz I know it
looks like a little bit crazy here but
let me let me walk you through this when
trying to explain what I'm trying to
present here and these items here are
the items that were they were pumped
during the zou under we have papaya
seeds dwarf weed told flax and then down
below we have magic logs but we don't
know the actual change the only thing
that they said was the drop rate was
decreased but that's kind of like an
indirect stop to magic seeds increasing
their value overall but if we start off
with papaya seeds we can see that it was
initially crashing and it was about 5.2
K and it initially offered two of those
seeds per drop but after the nerf and
now it offers three of them and it's
increased in value over time which is
now 11.5 K and if we look just below
that we can see on the left hand side we
see 10,500 GP with a little arrow
pointing to thirty four thousand five
hundred GP which gives us a difference
of a positive twenty four thousand GP
difference which overall is 228 point
six percent difference and if you know
how to calculate the difference your
percentage change difference I have the
little equations very tough they're very
simple all you do is you take the old
value and subtract it by the new value
then divided by the old value and then
multiply five hundred and then you get
the percentage change that has happened
during that time so we can see that
papaya seeds over all their loot if you
get that drop is now an overall increase
of 24,000 GP and now if we look at
fourth weed we can see that before and
after the nerve nothing has really
changed and its overall value but there
was still more included per drop going
from 20 drops to 30 if you look just
below that the drop was initially 19,000
it's now 28,500 which gives us an
increase of 9500 GP in value which is a
50% which is a 50% difference in change
and just below that we have toadflax
which is kind of fluctuating which is a
little clamp there at 2500 drop 20 of
those now it's 3000 kind of increase
just a little bit they bumped it up to
25 of those dropped and we can see that
what that one it's an increase about
12,500 VP which is about a 25% increase
in value and that drop and then at the
very bottom like I said we don't know
the actual drop rate of magic logs so I
couldn't really provide any solid kind
of data on what the actual changes but
we know that the actual value of the
seeds have gone up significantly next we
have the actual nerf drops and I do
apologize to kind of squeeze as much of
the items into one picture but I wanted
to showcase it so that you guys could
look at one picture and just get a good
understanding of what's really happen
and I forgot to include the timestamp of
when I've actually checked the prices of
the new value which is going to be
around June 29th 2017 so you're watching
this in the future you might want to
keep that in mind and then also the
values that you guys see in the first
bracket so with rely or you can see the
first drop what it was originally at was
112 500 is based on an average value of
the loot the for the nerf like a week
before the nerf and then the loot
afterwards or the new value that I'm
that the arrow is pointing to is the
value that it is currently a June 29th
when I check those prices if we just go
down the list we can see that or
was a pretty significant drop as well as
some other ones as well it didn't really
change in price but it did get dropped
from 10 of those to two of those so the
drop was initially 100 12,500 TV but now
it's 20 2500 which is a loss of 90,000
TPM value which is an 80%
yeah how great Long's that we're now
replacing mahogany planks which does
make sense because it's kind of like a
gold sink slash ruin sink you could use
the planks or you could use the logs at
the sawmill to convert them into planks
which is a gold sink or you could use
plank make which is a lunar spell which
is a ruin sink so that part does make
sense and I do agree with that and I do
agree with the whole nerf overall but
again subjective opinion here I think
Lynn Dirk was a little bit too hard but
again this is based upon you know
whatever you guys believe but we can see
mahogany planks were around 2,100 PP but
mahogany logs now are around 410 GP and
the actual dropped between those lutes
hasn't really changed so it's still
50/50 those but the drop value was
pretty big so initially 105,000 now
20,500 which is a loss of about eighty
four thousand five hundred GP and now if
we look at snapdragon see that one
hasn't really changed in value either
but it was dropped from two of those to
one of those only drop which goes from
eighty thousand drop loot to forty
thousand this is a 50% decrease in value
towards all seeds were declining in
value but after this nerf they started
to increase in value also the amount
that was dropped has been decreased from
two to one and we can see that it's not
as big of a difference between the runic
or and mahogany logs which goes from
thirty six two thousand to twenty one
thousand five hundred which is a loss of
14,500 GP value then we have matter rays
replacing raw shark and the raw shark
were around 950 GP upon the time around
the area before the nerf and then manta
rays currently around June 29th around
1300 de menthe drop was also a pretty
significant change going from 100 to 35
we can we can see it goes from a 95,000
drops to 40 5500 GP drop which is about
a fifty two point one percent decrease
in changed and so we have more drops I'm
not going to go into all of them I'm
just going to let you guys follow the
screen if you guys want to look at this
warrant and
just kind of look it over a little bit
if you want to
and finally I thought that you guys
would want to see this more importantly
to see the overall change between what
my route was what it could have been in
the past so I've taken all the values
that I've shown you guys in the list of
all those screenshots and taking the
total of the value of those items which
comes out to grow to around 1.2 or 1.3
mil which averages around 79 kg P where
the NIP comes around and now it's kind
of dropped to 780 K which is around an
average of 48 point 6 K then the
difference is we've lost Brazil has lost
around 480 3.5 K in value slowly from
these items alone this isn't looking at
any other item that was listed one thing
to keep in mind is I also didn't include
those Ola and the teleport which you can
see the very bottom of the screen right
there I know the part is really small
but all it's really saying is I haven't
include the actual drop value of those
around teleport because I wasn't able to
find the actual blog related to them
bumping it up to from 1 to 4 or
something like I believe it only couple
one and I was dropping forward but the
overall loss value is around 12 K so if
we take the average value of what it
used to be was not 40k and we take the
amount of donor teleport through up now
and then multiply that before it gives
us around 28 K so that's about it's
around 12 K loss hump so Ranna teleports
and value alone and we can see looking
at the upper portion overall there is
about a thirty eight point three percent
decrease in value from zora based off
what I've looked and passed and what the
values are now and when I was looking
with a blog 30 percent is a significant
change I know
maybe not a lot of you guys are big into
like percentages but 30 percent is a big
nerf
and to calculate the difference and see
what if actually comes out to now
current in its current market standpoint
being 38% that literally killed the boss
in my personal opinion again it's solely
up to you guys whether or not you want
to kill that boss so if we look at the
immune column section we can see at the
very bottom that I actually made fifty
six point one five mil and then if we
calculated everything from all those
drops and what they used to be if I had
killed Doral in the past that fifty six
mil would have actually been almost
seventy one point five mil which is a
pretty big difference we can actually
see at the write the overall loss
between the old dollar versus now
between those five hundred kills was
fifteen point three mil which is a
decrease of 21.4% in value which is a
little bit less was actually a lot less
than what they've actually calculated
from the table that I was showing
earlier I'm just showing you guys this
you guys can make your own decisions
based upon whether and what kills Ora
can tally up to you but I really wanted
to showcase a sense you know there was a
massive panic during that time and it is
a pretty big change and and it's
worthwhile knowing other than that guys
I think that's going to be out of that
if you like this video be sure Li the
like to show your support
be sure to subscribe for future content
be sure to leave a comment down below to
give me your thoughts on any ideas you
guys want to see in the future good luck
right you guys and until next time
[Music]